hi
welcome to the anthos deep dive this
will be part one of a two-part session
my name is vicky iglesias i'm a product
manager with google and i have with me
my colleague
i'm john murray i'm also a product
manager at google
let's dive in the first thing
you need to know about anthous is that
anthos doesn't just target one persona
within your organization
there are many personas that can benefit
from onboarding onto anthus and its
technologies
including the infrastructure operators
the service operators
and the developers and for those folks
there's going to be a lot of different
benefits
it could be that you're looking for
consistency in the way that you manage
your infrastructure and applications
you might be looking to put security
guard rails in place to make sure that
your developers have the autonomy they
need
and we'll walk through some of these
benefits as we go through the talk
when we're talking about anthos we
really talk about these five main
components and today we're going to talk
about the
bottom three here so we'll talk about
anthos gke
anthoconfig management and cloud logging
and monitoring
so these are really targeted at the
infrastructure operators and in part one
we'll focus here
and you'll see service operators and
developers and how they can benefit from
anthos
in part two so first
let's talk about anthos gke and why
customers choose gke
in general we break this down into four
parts
first it's really easy to start and this
is a lot of
the ways that people get started with
kubernetes in general
you've got a really intuitive console
that you can use you've got clis that
provide
the functionality that you need in order
to get up and running and scale your
services
and you can do this all in one click or
in one command and really have a lot of
the ongoing management handled by
gke sres so with that simplified
management what do we really mean
well you get inbuilt monitoring for all
your kubernetes clusters
whether they live in on-prem or in other
cloud providers
you can hook those all in and have all
of the monitoring and metrics show
up in a single pane of glass interface
within the google cloud console
so this is super helpful for wrangling
all the clusters that you might have and
all the workloads that you have
across your organization next
we have features like release channels
which help you with the ongoing
maintenance
that you might have with your kubernetes
clusters for example upgrading
you might not want to always upgrade to
the latest version or you might want to
upgrade to the latest version because it
has a feature that you're looking for
and so what we have
in these channels is the ability to pin
to a stream of releases
so for example if you're looking for
always the latest release
you can pin to the rapid channel and
that'll give you the release of
kubernetes that we've vetted
most recently some customers want to
have
more stable releases that we know have
worked well over time
and they can pin to the stable channel
which will give them
a slower upgrade cadence for folks that
are somewhere in between
you can pick our regular channel and get
the updates as they've been vetted
by folks in the rapid channel and then
we'll finally pass on into the stable
channel
so with features like that really we're
optimizing for
ease of management but we also optimize
for different
types of workloads right so if you have
machine learning workloads
or really intensive uh data programs
that you're running on your gke clusters
you might need some hardware
accelerators in order to enable those to
run at the highest performance
so with that we have the ability to
attach gpus
tpus and local ssd to your gke nodes
all through the declarative kubernetes
configuration in a really simple way
to optimize those workloads for you
additionally
we want to make sure that you can run
both your linux and windows workloads in
the same cluster
so with this we have support for windows
server containers
and they'll just show up right side by
side
in the same interfaces that i've shown
before with the same monitoring and
metrics
all in the same cluster so really useful
for those mixed workloads
as you're thinking about scaling up the
amount of workloads that you have in
your
kubernetes environment you're going to
want to make sure that your clusters
scale really well and that your
workloads scale really well
so one way we've helped with scaling
your workloads is to uh
implement cloud native load balancing
with cloud native
load balancing you can avoid a second
hop for your request coming from the uh
from the outside world through load
balancers
and go directly to your pods so now not
only do
is there one less place where you can
have a single point of failure
for your workloads but also you're
getting to your workloads with the least
latency possible
additionally we also think about how you
might scale up or scale out
your workloads in gke so for example you
might use
vertical pod auto scaling when you have
a workload that can't really scale
horizontally
but needs to scale vertically you don't
really understand
how much cpu or memory it might use you
can use vertical pod auto scaling
in order to watch that workload and as
it reaches the limits of what it needs
if it's available in the cluster it'll
automatically get those
resources allocated to it so that it can
keep running and won't crash or move to
another node
these are the kinds of features that
make running workloads in gke
as simple as possible additionally if
you don't want to think about
what size your nodes should be for your
gke clusters you can use the node auto
provisioner which will just provision
the right size nodes for the workloads
that you asked from your
api server and finally another way we've
helped with scaling
kubernetes to make sure that clusters
scale to large number of nodes
and recently we announced that we can
scale up to 15
000 nodes with a single gke cluster
so all this is to say that customers
choose gke
because we continue to innovate on your
behalf this is something that we are
constantly working on
and working with our top customers to
make sure that their needs are met
and that those can be used in the
simplest possible way for other users
we understand though that not everyone
can run on gcp
for various reasons so we want to make
sure that you can run anthos
and enthus gke in any place where you
want to run kubernetes cluster
so with that we'll start talking about
anthos gke
on-prem and really when you think about
on-prem deployment options you might ask
yourself why do customers need this
well one example might be that they have
a database somewhere
inside of their data center and they
want to have that workload as close to
the database as possible
so if they want to have that kubernetes
cluster inside their data center
another reason might be that they have
data locality restrictions and they have
to have
a cluster in a particular place and gcp
doesn't have a region there
so for these types of use cases we have
emphasis gk on-prem which will allow you
to deploy kubernetes clusters
inside your data center and we'll walk
through a high-level
architecture of how anthos gk on-prem
works
so first when you're trying to get
anthos gk on-prem installed
you'll point your laptop or a developer
workstation
at a vsphere api inside your data center
that vsphere api will then provision
what we call the admin workstation
this is a linux machine that bundles all
of the
utilities and binaries that we need in
order to deploy
the rest of the architecture so this is
really kind of the seed node
for the rest of what we'll talk about
once you have that
admin workstation stood up you're going
to deploy
the admin cluster and the admin cluster
is the control plane that allows you to
create
many user clusters and those user
clusters are the ones that we're going
to
hand over to the end users of kubernetes
this admin cluster makes sure that the
right number of nodes is provisioned
that the right plugins are installed
into into your clusters
that the right functionality is
available to your end users
and we'll make sure that that state
stays up to date so once you have that
admin cluster
that control plane up and running you
can start to create user clusters
and that is done by creating a
kubernetes
resource and applying that into the
admin cluster
once you do that the admin cluster will
look at the configuration that you've
asked for as far as what that cluster
should have in it
the size should be how many nodes it
should have and it will go ahead
and provision that user cluster for you
and then you can get some credentials
out of there
and hand them back to your users this
can
create up to 10 user clusters per
uh gk on on-prem installation and each
of those
10 user clusters can have 100 nodes this
really allows you to scale
to a large number of kubernetes clusters
within each
data center footprint and then provide
those to various use cases within your
organization
once you have those user clusters and
the master
the control plane up and running you'll
also want to include load balancing
and load balancing gets traffic into
your workloads
so the types of load balancers that we
have available today are one
inbuilt load balancer which is what we
recommend this is based on
uh some google technology that we
provide l3 load balancing on
on your on behalf of the clusters you
could also bring
an f5 uh big-ip if that was how you were
doing
uh the load balancing in your
organization or you could bring
your own load balancer that was not
fully integrated by us
and configure that to point at your user
clusters and your
uh admin control plane a lot of
flexibility there
to get the right setup that you need
on-prem is one of the places where we
think about clusters being uh
required but we also know that you have
other clouds that you've been uh
committed to and have workloads running
in so we want to make sure
that you can run anthos gke on any of
the other cloud providers
the next thing we'll talk about is
anthon's gke on aws
there's a lot of benefits to having this
gke on aws
uh one is you get all the functionality
that i talked about in the earlier uh
part of the talk where we're managing
clusters for you we're integrating
monitoring
those pieces and really it allows you to
integrate
those that functionality into your
existing aws footprint
so super useful stuff the pattern with
anthoc gke on aws is
that you'll have a jump host similar to
how we had
the uh the user laptop in in the ethos
gk on-prem example
and that jump host will have a binary on
it called enthos gke
and that binary will talk to the ec2 api
and provision again an admin cluster
which will act as your control plane
for other clusters that then you provide
to your users so once you've provisioned
that admin cluster
you're going to go ahead and run
commands against it
to provision your user clusters again
the same pattern that we had before
what we do get as a benefit by running
inside of aws
is we have an inbuilt load balancer in
elastic load balancing
elb that comes out of the box so you
don't have to
configure or run your own load balancer
in that case
as far as features that are available in
anthos gke on aws
you have the ability to have h8 control
planes auto scaling
in place upgrades and your storage
backed by aws's ebs
if you don't have an existing vpc and
want to just kick the tires you could
absolutely
create your own vpc through the enthos
gk on aws installer
or you can choose to install into an
existing vpc
and all of these clusters that you bring
up are going to be well integrated with
anthoconfig management
and those service management and cloud
run on anthos
which we'll talk about in part two of
this talk
so now that we have clusters all over
the place
how are we gonna manage all the
workloads across them how we're gonna
make sure that they are
as uniform as possible that we know
what's running well
you know we're gonna have uh some
challenges there and
anthos is willing to help you here so
we know that users have a lot of
different multi-cluster use cases
we talked about some around data
locality being near to databases but you
also might want to have highly available
services
you might have different environments
that have different clusters
and you might have for example a low
latency service that you want to have
with clusters that have are in different
regions
so the first thing that you might want
to do since if you're already a
kubernetes user is attach a cluster to
anthos that you've already provisioned
somewhere
through some other mechanism and we
allow that so you can bring your own
clusters to anthos
no matter how they are provisioned as
long as they're compliant
kubernetes clusters the way that you do
that
is you would register them through the
google cloud console or via the cli
and that would attach them to our to our
anthos control plane
the way that that actually works is that
we have a agent that runs inside of your
cluster
and that calls out of your cluster and
connects to our control plane in a
secure manner
it actually encrypts that connection
that's egressing
your environment and make sure that it's
secure
and then with that connection nailed up
we can start to do
a higher order things like provide low
balancing across clusters
or just show you your workloads running
for those clusters inside of the
google cloud console
another thing that you get out of
attaching these clusters is you get to
start
turning on and off features that you
might want to have using enthos so for
example you might want to turn on
anthon's config management which we'll
talk about uh in the last last half of
this talk
you might want to set up load balancing
across the clusters and you can do all
of that
through the the anthos ui
once they're attached they're going to
show up just like any other gke on gcp
cluster
so you'll have those listed here you'll
be able to see which ones should be
upgraded
what the capacity of those clusters is
and whether they're healthy
so super useful stuff so we can talk
about
multi-cluster ingress multi-cluster
ingress
allows us to have a single load balancer
ip
that can point to multiple clusters
within our anthos deployment
so now i can route people based on the
lowest latency cluster
that would reach them and if i have a
failover scenario
i can route to an additional cluster
that may be in a different region or a
different zone
or maybe in a data center so with these
features we're really trying to make
sure
that anthos has the ability to bring to
you
higher complex uh use cases in a really
simple way that maps to how we do things
in the kubernetes world
and with that we're going to go ahead
and take a look at how these things fit
together
through the cloud console and we're
going to look at how we manage our
clusters
from gke on gcp gk on aws
and gk on-prem
all right since we now seen how anthos
can get us clusters provisioned
and we've seen some of the methodologies
for how that's done let's take a look at
what we end up with
when we put all of these things together
and we'll explore this using the gcp
console
so here we are on the homepage i'm going
to go ahead and click on
the hamburger menu over here and then
down to anthos
the end those dashboard is meant to tell
you your cluster status what features
you have enabled on each of those
clusters
we can see here that we have six
clusters currently
in anthous management and we'll see here
that
some of them are provided by vsphere so
this is our gk on-prem cluster
we also have some in u.s central within
uh gcp
us east within gcp then also one
registered
with enthus from aws you can see all
these clusters show up
in the same place and we can also check
on
the current status of their
configurations to make sure that they're
synced
to the get ops configuration that we've
put into our repository
we can see that all from the anthos
dashboard here
if we go into the kubernetes dashboard
we can actually see some
deeper insights into what's running in
our clusters at this at this time
so here we have the list of all of our
clusters we can see that we have
clusters again
in gcp aws and vsphere and they all show
up
in the same pane class here we're going
to go over and look at our workloads
so this can be used as a ui for
kubernetes
so here i have a saved faceted view
for my dope app this is an application
that's running across a bunch of
different clusters so we can
see here that i have some running inside
of
my production clusters some in my
staging clusters
and some on my dev clusters on prem so
you can see all of these in a single
pane of glass and when i click into
these workloads i can actually
start to see some of the monitoring and
metrics of how they're operating so you
can have this
as a developer portal as well so they
can help debug i can also see
the events that might have been fired
for this particular
workload and i can go ahead and look at
my services
that were provisioned in here so a lot
of functionality that can be found
for any of your clusters that are
registered with nthos
the other thing that you might want to
do is check out your logs and have an
integrating logging integrated logging
view
so with that we have the logs view
where you can filter on a bunch of
different things including
the container type the cluster or a
particular kubernetes node if that's
giving you trouble
so if we click on kubernetes cluster we
can see these are the
logs from our clusters that are
registered in gcp
and we can see all of the information
about the resources that have been
applied
we can also go ahead and click into a
particular container workload
and see the faceted view of where those
are running so here we can see
the clusters i can click on for example
my on-prem
dev cluster and i can see all the logs
for my workloads running there
i can then filter that down for example
by
namespace so i might click into the cube
system namespace because something isn't
quite running right
and i can start to see all of the
information about things that are going
wrong there
next i wanted to show how i might add a
namespace
to all of my clusters since i have the
ability to manage these clusters in a
uniform way
how how might i add a particular
namespace
all right so here we have git repository
that contains all the configuration that
we want shared across
our clusters so for example if i wanted
to add a namespace
i could go to the namespaces folder and
add a file in here
that has some kubernetes manifest that
i'd want added so i'm going to go ahead
and add a new file here
and i'm gonna call it namespaces slash
my awesome
and in that i'm gonna create a
namespace.yaml
i'm actually gonna overload this a
little bit and i'm gonna also include
not just a namespace definition but
actually a pod and so we'll see my
namespace get created
which is going to be called my awesome
app
and we're going to have a pod created
which is going to be this web server pod
so we should see when we go back to the
console that these are all showing up in
our clusters so let's go ahead and
commit these
now when you commit these these changes
they can be reviewed by folks
you can be you can have a transaction
log of all these changes that have gone
through
just like any other git repo so let's go
take a look at what this looks like
inside of our console so i go back to my
kubernetes engine clusters here
and now i should be able to see and
filter on
my namespace that i just created and see
those pods coming up with that web
server
enabled so let's see here okay
i see that i have all my clusters here i
go to the workloads pane which is going
to contain all the workloads in all my
clusters
and i'm going to go ahead and reset this
one which was for my previous
application i was using i'm going to
look for my new app called my
awesome app great
so we can see here we've already got
some of these coming up so we have a
prod west cluster
that's running our pod and our dev
on-prem cluster
so that's it we've got things running
and now we'll hand it off to john
who's going to take us through a little
bit more in detail what acm
anthous config management can provide
thanks fake
i'm going to talk a little bit about
anthos config management
ethos config management helps you manage
all of your configuration policies at
scale
and includes three different components
there's config sync
for managing configuration policy
controller for managing your governance
and compliance
policies and config connector for
bringing gcp
into atos first let's talk about
config sync and how it helps you manage
configuration and scale
so when you've got a large and diverse
hybrid
environment that runs on kubernetes you
have a couple of scale problems
one is scaling your team you've got many
people on the operator team
who need to apply configuration changes
to that environment
whether it's on gcp on-prem or in other
public clouds
and as that team grows making changes
against that environment by running
commands through cute control becomes
harder and harder to keep straight
you don't know who's doing what and you
don't necessarily have a record of
things that have changed
on the flip side all of those clusters
and all of the different teams sharing
them
get bigger and more diverse in multiple
locations
and it makes it harder and harder to
roll out changes that affect the entire
environment
so the way we deal with that in
anthoconfig management
is through a tool called config sync
that puts all of your configuration in a
centralized
policy repository that's based on git
that means everybody in the operating
team can collaborate together
using methods that they typically use
for application development
pull requests and code reviews and that
helps your team work better together
and then by connecting that
multi-platform environment back to that
central repository
it helps your environment work better by
having a single
centralized source of truth for all of
your configuration
config management stores that
configuration as a secure repository and
then rolls it out to all of your
kubernetes clusters
and to antho service mesh and that means
all of your configuration is auditable
that there's a record of every change
that's made to the environment
stored in that git repository it's
revertable
in terms of being able to roll back the
last
best good state uh it's transactional
and that changes can be grouped together
and rolled out all at once
and it's self-healing that single source
of truth
is kept in sync with all of your
clusters
and any local changes are guarded
against drift so that you can be assured
that it is applied
how that looks in a production
environment might be something like this
so if you have google cloud platform
with a gke cluster running on the left
and an on-prem data center that's
running gk and prem on the right
you can connect those through cloud
interconnect and have a single
common private network the policy
repository that holds all of your
configuration
can live on-prem or it can live in gcp
in this case
it's running on-prem and that policy
repository allows you to
define your configuration using
abstract namespaces or inheriting
configuration across
multiple teams so you can define
policies that apply globally
in addition to that you can specify
configuration
should be rolled out to a single cluster
or a set of clusters when you need to
configure things differently
now let's talk about managing policies
at scale with policy controller
policy controller is included in
anthoconfig management and it is based
on the open policy agent
gatekeeper project in open source it
allows you to manage
policy at multiple stages of config
deployment
and so you can inspect configuration
before it gets applied
you can enforce policies at the api
layer inspecting every call that comes
into your kubernetes environment
and then you can run audits using the
same policies to look at
historical changes or simply just to
inspect things without necessarily
enforcing them actively
and that means that any client that is
connected to your
clusters is respecting
the guardrails that you have in place
that enact your security and compliance
policies
those policies are diverse and that's
why we support custom
policies in policy controller the policy
controller also comes with a default
policy library
that includes 27 constraint templates
that
are used for common use cases that we
see all the time with our customers
and these are policies that are
maintained by google and
included as part of the distribution
that might be something like
restricting a role binding to only your
corporate domain
or ensuring that mutual tls is turned on
so that all of the traffic running over
your service match
is encrypted in transit at all times
finally let's talk about managing gcp
resources
as part of memphis
gcp config connector is designed to
expose all of the popular gcp services
that our customers use as part of
kubernetes
and anthos it does that by
taking every popular gcp api
and turning it into a kubernetes api so
that when you're deploying applications
through cubecontrol
through a git based deployment like
config management or through api clients
you can
treat gcpus that were just another part
of that
kubernetes environment that means you've
got native
native api service for gcp and
you can specify the resources that you
would like that underlie your
applications whether that's a database
or storage bucket in declarative
configuration
and that configuration will be
continuously reconciled against the
cloud
and made guarded against drift
this is available now and it is included
as part of antos config manager so
all of these components can be installed
separately but they can all be used
together
and that means you can store all of your
configuration whether it's kubernetes
service mesh or gcp in a single common
git repository
roll that out and check it for policies
that ensure that it's compliant with
your
security rules and your operational
controls
and extend that way of managing
configuration
from kubernetes all the way to gcp and
that's santos config management
that concludes part one of our deep dive
stay tuned for part two where we'll talk
about cloud render and those
and anthony service members on behalf of
vic
and myself and all of google cloud
thanks for joining us today